this relationship between jeffrey  epstein and delaney maxwell  was really a partnership on a sexual  level at a financial level  i worked for helen and jeffrey in his  new york mansion  and i asked gilan what her relationship  was with jeffrey  because she appeared to be more like an  employer or a co-worker  she told me they were married and then  she told me  that evening that they weren't actually  married but that they were dating  and he was cheating on her okay so what  is it  [Music]  i think that one of the saddest things  actually that i've read about the whole  thing  is in the deposition when she was asked  what her relationship  with epstein was and was it a  relationship and she sort of answered  saying  she wasn't really sure she was you know  part friend part fixer she was the one  who  who would satisfy his every whim  the only boyfriend i've ever heard about  was jeffrey epstein  who doesn't strike me as a terribly good  choice  you